there was a simpsons episode where he
starts mixing like
um sleeping pills with like pet pills
and he's driving his truck and i like i
want to see what happens with this red
bull and nitro called
that's the lineup of drugs this is gonna
be so fun
this is yeah let's start with love
yes
yeah so one one thing we'll eventually
somehow talk about it'll be a theme
throughout is that you're also russian
yes a little bit less than me but how
about
why because i'm from ukraine oh you're
from ukraine
okay well no because you came here a
little bit when you were younger
yeah i i i came here when i was 13 so i
saturated a little bit of the russian
soul
i i marinated in the ocean so a little
deeper i haven't told anyone this but
i'll be glad to tell you
devadish um i haven't been back since
i was two and next summer it looks like
me my buddy chris williamson who's
also a podcaster he's british modern
wisdom he looks like apollo
we're we looks like we got a
videographer the god he looks like the
god of apollo yeah he's like a mother
so we're gonna go for the first time to
see where i came from
which is ukraine we're going to go to
levov and either st petersburg or moscow
probably st petersburg or both
it's going to be intense it's going to
be a lot of panic attacks i feel
and your russian is okay
no you can't talk russian ukraine or
it's like they get offended
yeah but then you also want to go to
russia yeah
i don't know for me there's several
people in russia i want an interview on
a podcast
okay so one one of them is uh guerrilla
promon which is a mathematician
and the other person is putin you know
my favorite food and story is
do you know this no when he had merkel
with him do you know this story no
merkel's scared of dogs like petrified
of dogs so he brings in his like
like like uh um black lab it's a
labrador it's like the sweetest animal
and it's all over her and there's
pictures and she's sitting like this and
she's terrified and he's like what's
wrong angela
he's just completely trolling her yeah
he's aware of the sort of uh the
narrative around him yeah
and then he plays with it yes he enjoys
it it's a very russian thing
my friend wanted to film about me he
goes i realize you guys aren't like us
at all you just like like
look at us and then i started telling
him stories about the upbringing
and he's like oh my god and as i'm
telling them like wow this stuff is
really crazy like what
how we are wired who's the wii your
friend is the russian the friends of
america i'm saying the way russians are
brought up
and the way maybe i don't think it was
just my family i bet you had similar
things like
here's an example i i was i had a buddy
staying with me he had a problem with
his roommate so he crashed my place fine
i went to the gym and i come back
and he goes oh there was and my
apartment building is four four
apartments so it's not like a huge thing
he goes oh there was someone knocking at
your door so you know i i told him blah
blah and
and for me and i want to know if you're
the same way
if i'm at someone's house that's not my
own and some knocks in the door
i wouldn't even think to answer it like
if i had an apple here might be i'd eat
it i'd
cut it whatever i'm not gonna it just
doesn't enter my head to smash into my
face
the the thought of answering the door if
it's not my house
it would never enter my head would it
enter your head no but why
but he's an american so someone's at the
door he goes and opens it even though
it's not his house
i would never do that i would never
think to do that
that is so strange that you pick some
very obscure thing to
delineate americans i don't think that's
obscure because i think it
speaks to how we perceive strangers with
americans everyone's friendly and with
us it's like
no no like you have that moat and i
think that's a that
percolates into many different aspects
of how we relate to people and i have to
undo a lot of that
that's true you're right there's the
relationship i formed there were in
russia or very deep
yeah close and then there's the
strangers the other
that you don't trust by default it takes
a long time to go over the moat
of trust for a long time until recently
whenever i said anything to anyone my
brain
ran a scan that said if this person
turns on you
would this can they use this against you
and i would do everything i said with
strangers
and after a while it's like you know
what maybe they will but i'm strong
enough to take it but
this is not how americans think well
here's another one let me ask you this
sorry i'm taking over the interview
people asked about like
uh advice for work right like i had this
there was this
party i went to and basically everyone
had their own problems and everyone else
gave their advice right
and someone was having a problem with
the co-worker and the advice these
two americans gave them is oh sit down
and have a talk with them
and to me this is like the last case
last
resort like first you have to see what
you can without showing your hand
showing your vulnerability only when
everything hasn't worked out or you're
like all right let me sit down with you
and try to have it out with you
probably but for them the first thing is
like sit down and be like
oh you're causing me problems and blah
blah so i perceive that right away as a
threat
that this person sees an antagonism
between us and also as a weakness that
i'm getting to them
so my reaction isn't um how do i make it
better my reaction is to reinforce
my position and see what i can to
marginalize them
usually i haven't worked in a corporate
setting in a long time but it's not i
don't approach it the way an american
would like i'm glad you came and talked
to me now i probably would because it's
gonna be a friend
so you attribute that to the russian
upbringing as opposed to you have deep
uh psychological issues i think there's
a synonymous done
wait am i would you think differently
maybe a few years ago
um i don't know i i i think you lost me
at the
because you kind of said that you're
kind of implying you have a deep
distrust of the world
like the world does i think the default
setting would be distrust yeah
but
i would put it differently is i almost
ignore the rest i don't even
acknowledge it i just uh savor
i save my love and trust for the small
circle of people
i agree but when that person is being
confrontational or as they perceive it
as being open
now there's a situation how do you how
would you handle that
like like a cold wind blows he's just
kind of like yeah but it's not like
this is an opportunity for us to work
out our differences it's a cold wind
it's not a hug that's my point i think
it's a hug
you're so suspicious what it really is
is a cold wind
i'm so inhumane that's something to be
scared of it's a cold winter person
but it's not this is great but it's not
a source of like i'm not suspicious
of like i'm not uh anxious
i would say or like living in fear of
the rest of the world
anymore oh i agree but you're not
receptive to that person right
that's all i'm saying and they are
you